- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problems.
So, today we're going to learn how to not
take no for an answer.
Over to you, Ryan Seacrest.
(rooster crowing)
(upbeat music)
- What do you think the secret
to your success has been?
- I think, for me,
- Like if they were going to ask you,
Ryan what can I do, what
would you tell them?
- It is absolute focus and determination
and a love for what you're pursuing.
And I think they, as
I did, will be told no
a lot, and that no is something
you can't always listen to.
Like, sometimes that no can become a yes.
But, I think you've got to find out
something you love and pursue it
with a lot of focus.
- So, along your path to success you're
going to get a lot of no's.
You get a lot of people saying no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
You can expect it.
And, you know what?
A lot of those no's are justified
because when you are first starting
something, you're going to suck.
Your quality, your
output is going to suck.
It's not going to be very good because
you don't have the talent.
You don't have the skills.
You haven't put in the effort yet.
And so, you can expect people to say no
and it's not a malicious no, it's not,
I want you to fail no.
You just aren't providing
them with enough value yet.
And, that's okay, but
if you have the passion
for what you want to
do, this is a big dream,
this is a big goal of yours, then you
have to push through.
There's this great clip
of Sylvester Stallone
where he says I love getting no's,
because a no just means a yes.
He sees it as a challenge.
The fact that he got a no is a challenge
for him to want to go and push harder
and go faster and do more and prove,
prove to, prove to them but prove
to himself that he's good enough.
That he can do it.
And so, I think it's really important
that you use negativity, you use no's,
you use criticism as a
kick not down, but forward.
Use a no as motivation to
want to go and do better
and eventually get the
yes, as opposed to, I suck.
I'm never going to get this.
This is never going to work out.
I think it's really important
to be hard on yourself,
but most people kick
themselves down instead of
kicking themselves forward.
So, if you can learn to use your no's
as motivation to do better, then you're
on the fast path to success.
So, the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what was the most painful no
that you've gotten in your life?
I want to know what it
is, so go in deep today.
Leave it down in the comments below
and I want you to, as you write it out,
release it so it doesn't
hold you back anymore.
I'm curious, put it down in the comments.
I also want to give a quick shoutout
to Ed Reyes from Creative New Media, Inc.
Ed, and thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for
another shot of Entspresso.
(upbeat music)
- Don't take no for an answer.
If it's not working well that night
it's not you, it's the audience.
Blame it on the audience.
Because if it worked on Friday night,
it ought to work on Saturday night
and if it doesn't it's their fault.
It's over simple but, you know what?
It works as a formula.
Just go on and do the Sunday night show
and forget Saturday night.
Keep kicking them in the nuts.
- There's something about an entrepreneur
that is somewhat sort
of anti-establishment,
somewhat disrespectful of
the previous generation.
And, although that can grate people
the wrong way a little bit, that's a
really important element actually.
You need to be passionate about
what you want to work on, and don't
take no for an answer when people
out there are giving you advice,
and saying, no this'll never work.
I mean, you look at eBay.
The idea that in 1995, that you could
create something over the internet,
which is this brand new thing that nobody
was really using at the time, except for
scientists and academics, and it would be
a place where strangers could actually
do business with on
another, could actually
exchange merchandise for
money without ever meeting.
And, the notion that people could
actually buy and sell
cars over the internet.
I mean, that's crazy, right.
It's totally crazy.
So, in fact lots and lots of people
told me that it was crazy.
And, I didn't, I have to say I didn't
have this vision, oh, it's going to
take over the world.
It's going to be this
fantastic thing overnight.
I didn't have that kind
of delusion, either.
But, I did say, you know what?
There's something worth trying here.
It's not crazy.